- Talk with a lot of people
that you think are inspiring.
We do that still a lot, we
go to meet people that we
think are doing such a great
job, or that we look up to.
And then you get so
much energy out of that.
And I think that can
help you get a long way.
- I'm Emilie Tabor, one
of the founders of IMA,
Influencer Marketing Agency.
- I'm Maddie, I'm also one
of the founders of IMA,
Influencer Marketing Agency.
What we do is, we create
influence for marketing strategies
for all sorts of brands.
So we create the strategy
but we also fully execute it.
So from influencer matchmaking,
to setting up the strategy,
to full execution and
measurement, and reporting.
- We started working
together on a platform
called fashionista.com.
This was more of a Pinterest,
but then for fashion.
Maddie was there, more
from the influencer side,
really building up the influencer network,
and also the strategic
side of the platform.
And I was there more for the
commercial end of the platform,
really seeing how we can
make it into a business.
- I think, because we're still very young,
a lot of people in our
team are the same age.
So sometimes it's hard...
or it's a challenge to
be part of the team,
but also be a leader, so to say.
As a young entrepreneur,
to set up a company
and also be an example
for the rest of the team.
- We launched in 2010,
but then we changed our
name around about 2012,
to Influencer Marketing Agency.
And that's when a lot of
things changed for us.
The market started changing,
as well they started
to know influencer marketing,
and what it entailed.
So we didn't have to explain it as much.
It was starting to become part of the
natural marketing mix for a lot of brands.
And also, we built up
such a track record that,
we could really prove the
effect of influencer marketing.
- Of course we want to keep on growing,
but we want to keep on
pioneering in this field.
We want to stay, not
necessarily the biggest,
I think it's more about
the best and the quality
of our work that we wanna be known of.
And then next to that,
we want to also see what we can do more.